[Music]
okay so i was at this meeting a long
time ago with google and youtube i don't
even know if i'm allowed to talk about
this yet but it was so long ago proud it
doesn't matter uh but eric schmidt was
there and he said something that
i
remember super clearly to this day i'll
never forget the quote which was
every problem that we have
is a problem at scale and the more i
think about that
the crazier it is i mean it makes a lot
of sense youtube is a huge site so
youtube right now in 2022 has 2.6
billion
monthly active users
that means that if there's a problem
that's so small it only affects
0.1 percent of people on youtube
that problem now affects 2.6 million
people so if you're running a company
that big that affects this many people
like there's gonna be a lot of decisions
that come across their plate that are
going to affect large groups of people
and obviously there's got to be a
threshold
that you set where you can't do tons of
things every single day but once it
reaches the threshold then you got to
make a choice so maybe oh you know
something comes up that's affecting a
third of youtube users that makes 4k
videos loads slowly or something all
right we'll do something about that or
hey looks like three percent of youtube
users are getting dislike bombed so
we'll do something about it we'll just
get rid of dislikes from the whole site
but there are still going to be small
little issues all the time that are
below that threshold that affect a tiny
tiny fraction of the site
0.1 0.01 percent
and that isn't a big enough issue to
spend money on fixing but it's still
affects millions of people but this
issue i really just from my experience
on youtube i have to think that it has
gotten above that threshold
and that is comment spam
so really any recently uploaded video
you go to on youtube by a relatively
active creator you will undoubtedly come
across comments with duplicate names and
profile pictures like this thanks for
watching message right away i have
something for you thanks for the
feedback expect more videos very soon
send direct message i have something for
you congratulations you've been selected
amongst our shortlisted winners and
they're usually the first or only reply
on a lot of the most recent and most
popular comments on any video doesn't
really matter what the comment is about
they'll figure if you're leaving a
comment you're engaged enough to see it
and fall for it and their goal is to get
you off of youtube onto a telegram
message or whatsapp message now if
you're thinking well damn that's stupid
that's obviously not going to work it's
clearly fake
well that's what i would think too but
i started getting emails and tweets
first it was like one email a day or
someone once would tweet at me
and then it was two a day or three a day
and then it was several every day
now at this point every day i wake up to
at least a dozen new emails of people
sending me screenshots of conversations
they think they've had with me just
checking to make sure they sent the
money to the right place or whether or
not the paypal payment went through
these people are claiming to have a
giveaway prize ready to ship and they
just need you to pay one or 200 bucks
for shipping and if that's just the
people who have thought to email me
imagine how many other people are
falling for this and not emailing me
that i'm not seeing like that is a
serious bummer and the crazy part to me
is you would think the comment section
would be this precious
priority for youtube because it's such a
unique feature of the site this is one
of the only places that you can
facilitate real conversations between
the creators and the audience between
you and i
it's what makes youtube youtube like i
remember back when i started on youtube
i had email notifications turned on for
everything so every new comment and
every new subscriber i got an email for
it and i would reply to every single
comment on every single video
for years actually but this was my
portal into the community now these days
obviously i can't reply to everything
but i do still try to spend a lot of
time in the comments section and talking
to people but i end up spending most of
my time blocking channels of people
trying to scam my audience out of money
and keep in mind this is just the spam
flavor of the moment like these spammers
like any other bad actors are always
going to try to adapt and evolve and be
as effective as possible all the time so
like on my channel if i'm doing a
giveaway or even if i'm not they'll know
they can slip in and talk about like
maybe doing a tech giveaway but on
jacksepticeye's channel he just did a
video about a month ago talking about
how commenters will try to get you to go
to their adult sites with just copying
and pasting another highly rated comment
and then just getting a bunch of bots to
upvote it to the top linus made a video
this year on comment spam his channel
gets plenty of crypto stuff along with
pc related giveaways and you can imagine
on any mr beast video or any channels in
that cinematic universe there's just
going to be money giveaway spam there's
just so much spam and with the number of
places the number of channels that i've
seen this comment spam running rampant
on i feel like it has to be associated
with
some level of negative sentiment of just
a bad feeling
of spending time in the youtube comments
section so now there are moderation
tools that youtube has built to help
keep comments and check right they've
gotten better over time there's an
automatic spam filter that does a pretty
decent job and catches a lot of stuff
and just recently this button to hide
user from channel will actually work
retroactively so it'll block the channel
but then also remove all the comments
they've ever made on any of my videos
but i've spent a lot of time doing this
and the more time you spent trying to
keep up with the spam the more you
realize that not enough is being done so
now youtuber theo joe you might have
heard of him he's made an open source
tool that will scan for spam comments
and is much better than youtube at
identifying all of them and just on my
last video alone out of around 6 000
comments scanned it found that nearly 2
000 of them were identified as spam 2
000
spam comments look i don't know how bad
something has to get to get on youtube's
radar to cross that threshold but if 30
of the comments on my new video are spam
that's just not a good look so okay what
should be done that's the real question
right
uh and i think there are two things
one is a community built solution
and two is a youtube built solution
but only one of those things actually
exists effectively right now so the
community built solutions can actually
put a dent in things by users that are
active and and going through and doing
this type of stuff all the time so that
tool by theo joe that i mentioned
earlier it's multi-platform it works on
windows and on mac and if you plug in
your youtube info you can purge youtube
comments according to its much more
accurate filters and criteria which is
super helpful for creators that
implement it i am definitely going to
try it and then other people can
download it and run other videos through
it to mass report comments on other
videos and other channels
now that doesn't delete those comments
but hopefully
the mass reporting of these types of
comments can help train youtube's
automatic filters to more effectively
remove them will it actually work
i don't know but i promise you no matter
how good these community built solutions
get
nothing can touch the effectiveness
of youtube building a fix themselves
and we know that to be true because the
community built solutions are amazing
and the problem's still here so
youtube has to do something about it now
i'm not expert but i have been on
youtube longer than i haven't been on
youtube
crazy to say that
so looking at these youtube comments
even though these are all pretty
obviously spam comments to me clearly
they're getting through the spam
detection filter that youtube's built
so a comment moderation tool to nuke
them all would be the ideal right now
like i mentioned earlier they steal the
uploader's profile picture to try to be
convincing but then they also make
literally dozens of accounts really
quickly so blocking one of them and
hiding all of their past activity from
the channel which works
it only works for one set of spam
comments that one spam account left on
my last video alone like i said tons of
spam there's almost 40 different
accounts leaving comments and each one
of them has left anywhere from 1 to 111
spam comments so as of right now you can
already block certain words from
appearing in the body of a youtube
comment so if somebody leaves a comment
with a certain word in it it will just
not show up and that makes a lot of
sense it works for like if someone tries
to put an address or your phone number
or an offensive word or any number of
things that may be part of the spam
flavor of the moment that you can just
nix right in the bud
that's super useful but like i said
these bots are smart or at least the
people making them are they're already
adapting to that by cramming as much
information as they can into the
username now so not just the body of the
spam comment itself so the best solution
i can think of right now would be for
youtube to let us
ban
words from user names so that right off
the bat i can just ban anyone who tries
to use my name in their own username
it's the easiest way to stop
impersonation type spam from occurring
and i know it might sound messy or brute
force and you might be concerned about
innocent users getting caught in the
crossfire hey what if someone has the
same name as me but listen
this is the same company that saw a
fraction of users getting dislike
brigaded and decided to turn off
dislikes for the entire site so to me
this tool seems to be not that bad and
who knows maybe someday in the future
youtube's ai will get advanced enough
that if you make a brand new account
with the same profile picture and name
as the person whose videos you're
commenting on and then leave a hundred
comments in an hour that it'll trip
something and it'll recognize it as spam
and delete it but in the meantime a psa
myself and other creators will never ask
you for money or for a shipping address
or to dms on telegram and if we do have
a giveaway going out we have verified
accounts and will never message you from
any other account so if you click on an
account and it doesn't go to our channel
that's a pretty good sign
okay
that's it for now youtube
get on it
that's it thanks for watching
catch you guys the next one
peace
[Music]